THANK YOU IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME AND SEEING WE HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS HERE I'D LIKE TO START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE- A GOOD
AFTERNOON AND I'LL BE BRIEF ON
THIS WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY IN
PERSON OR BY PHONE- THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS 877-692-8957.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE
ZERO ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS. ONE
EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO
ZERO THE NUMBER CAN ALSO BE
FOUND ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
AND DISPLAYED ON YOUR SCREENS
FOR THOSE CALLING IN PLEASE MUTE
YOURSELF ALL IN THEIR QUEUE I TO
LIMIT ANY BACKGROUND NOISE FOR
EACH BILL HEARD TODAY THEY'LL BE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO WITNESSES
REPORT AND TWO WITNESSES
OPPOSITION EACH WILL BE PROVIDED
TO MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES CALLING AND
YOU'LL BE PLACED. FILL YOUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION A
WILL BE ALTERNATED. WHEN IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
PRES PLUS ONE THEN ZERO OF ME
YOURSELVES IN ORDER TO SPEAK BE
BRIEF LIMITING YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. WITH THAT- WE WILL
BEGIN- IN THE- SUB. AND
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY WOULD BE
THAT MR CHOI WILL BE
SUBSTITUTING FOR MR BIGELOW AS
VICE CHAIR TODAY. AND I WOULD WE
HAVE ONE OTHER HERE MISTER CORK
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN THANK
YES THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
I ACCEPT TE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHAT THE AMENDMENTS
DO IS SIMPLY MAKE SURE. THAT YOU
CAN'T HAVE ALCOHOL AND- CANNABIS
AT THE SAME EVENT THAT IS. STILL
CONTINUES TO BE THE STATE LAW.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES DO IS IT
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
GRANT A TEMPORARY LICENSE FOR
THE SALE OF CANNABIS AB DE
PERMITTED MENUS. UP SOME OF
THOSE MENUS A BIT VENUES HAVE
BEEN DENIED CANNABIS RETAIL
LICENSES BECAUSE THE- OUR VENUE
HAS AN ABC LICENSE. AND
THEREFORE THEY WERE ABLE TO HOLD
IT WHAT THIS BILL DOES ALLOW US
TO DO IS TO SUSPEND THAT THE-
THE LOCATION COULD SUSPEND THAT
ABC LICENSE ARE FOR THE PURITY
OF THE EVENT UP UNTIL SIX IN THE
AM OF THE NEXT DAY. IN THAT
WOULD THEN ALLOW THAT VENUE TO
HAVE THE OF THAT BECAUSE THERE'S
NO WAY THEY WOULD BE SELLING
ALCOHOL SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
MAIN. DOT CONCERNED ABOUT HERE
IT ALSO CLARIFIES PROVISIONS FOR
SPECIAL EVENT LOCATIONS. ARE
THAT WISH TO OBTAIN LICENSES TO
SELL CANNABIS TEMPORARILY. OUR
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW
CANNABIS LICENSES TO. ALL
LICENSEES SO RIGHT NOW IF YOU
BRING CANNABIS TO ADVANCE. YOU
HAVE TO THROW AWAY WHAT YOU DO
WHAT YOU DON'T USE. OF WHAT WE
WOULD SAY HERE IS PROVIDING YOU
COULD GET IN THE STATE'S TRACK
AND TRACE SYSTEM. SO IT'S
TRACKED AND TRACED UNTIL IT
COMES TO THAT LOCATION. IF YOU
CAN GET IT IN THE STATE SYSTEM
TRACK AND TRACE AS YOU BRING IT
BACK HOME. THEN EVERYTHING'S
FINE YOU CAN SELL IT SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO- DESTROY UNUSED
INVENTORY- REDUCES IMPORTANT.
THE LET'S COLLEGES SUPER
RECYCLING. I WITH ME TODAY IS MY
GOOD FRIEND AMY JENKINS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK FOR AT FOR INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL- I WAS VERY
PLEASED TO PARTNER WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AB ON AB TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH PERMITTED THE ISSUANCE OF
TEMPORARY EVENT LICENSES- TO
ALLOW FOR THE SALE AND
CONSUMPTION OF CANNABIS EDIT AND
EXPRESSLY PERMITTED BY A LOCAL
JURISDICTION THIS HARD FOUGHT
LEGISLATION WITH CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES. TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND TO THAT END
WE INCORPORATED NUMEROUS
PROVISIONS INTENDED TO SAFEGUARD
AGAINST THE CONSUMPTION OF
CANNABIS AND TOBACCO AND ALCOHOL
ON THE SAME PREMISES AS WELL AS
OTHER IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTOCOL. I'M AROUND
TO THESE TEMPORARY CANNABIS
EVENTS WHAT WE DIDN'T
CONTEMPLATE AT THAT TIME WAS HOW
THE ABC WOULD INTERPRET STATUTE
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IS AND
TRADITIONAL VENUES WHERE WE
WOULD LIKE AS AN INDUSTRY TO
HOST A TEMPORARY EVENT IF THAT
VENUE HAS AN ALCOHOL LICENSE IT
IS TYPICALLY DISALLOWED. SO WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO HOST SUCH
EVENTS- YOU KNOW IN THOSE
PARTICULAR LOCATION SO IT'S
REALLY REALLY NARROWED OUR
OPTIONS AND SO THIS IN IN MY
MIND REALLY CLARIFIES WHAT THE
ULTIMATE INTENT WAS ORIGINALLY
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
TWENTY- BY EXPRESSLY SAYING YOU
CAN IN FACT. HOST A TEMPORARY
EVENT WITH LOCAL APPROVAL WITH
THE STATE LICENSE FOLLOWING ALL
THE APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS- ON
EVENT AT A VENUE THAT ALSO HAS
AN ABC LICENSE SO I KNOW THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEN TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS IN COMMITTEE- ONTO
TO. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARITY
WE ALSO SECI A VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PER INSTEAD IN
THE BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE PRODUCT THAT IS NOT SOLD TO
BE RETURNED ADD TO THAT CANNABIS
RETAILER VIA A LICENSED
DISTRIBUTOR A MICRO BUSINESS. SO
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TODAY AND THINK THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE- AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SHE'S A PER HOUR HE IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES A SUPPORT
MR CORP. THAT'S UP. I DON'T HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL WITNESS NOW THANK
YOU. ANY OF THOSE IN THE ROOM
WITH YOUR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T SEE ANY I
WILL GO TO THE PHONES- MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY. THE PEOPLE IN
THE PHONES. THANK YOU TO REX
PRESS SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO PLEASE. NO LINES IN Q.
FOUR SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION. BY
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AB TWENTY TWO TEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. BUT WE
HAVE ONE OPPOSITE I'M SORRY. NOT
ON THE PHONE THE LIGHT HERE SO
YOU SAID YOU YOU MAY PROCEED FOR
A MAIN OPPOSITION WITH OKAY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO AND DAMAGING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SKEWS ME WE
WALKED A LITTLE WAYS TO GET
HERE. MY NAME IS CHRIS HAVE LEFT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR ALCOHOL
JUSTICE ORIGINAL POSITION HAN
THIS BILL WAS TO OPPOSE- WHAT WE
ARE GRATEFUL THAT THE ALCOHOL
LICENSE SUSPENSION AMENDMENT WAS
ADDED. WE ARE STILL UNABLE TO
REMOVE ALL OUR OPPOSITION. THE
BILL SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE. THE
THREATS TO UNDER AGE.
PARTICIPANTS IF ADMITTED. AND
LIMIT ADMITTANCE TO ONLY THOSE
TWENTY ONE AND OLDER. WE ALSO
SUGGEST THAT THE LANGUAGE BE
ADDED TO SPECIFICALLY PREVENT
ALCOHOL COMPANY CO SPONSORSHIP
AND CO BRANDING OF CANNABIS
EVENTS AT THESE TYPE OF IN USE.
OUR POSITION IS MODIFIED TO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM- MISTER CORPORATE
YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE ON THE
BILL WELL FIRST I WANNA SAY
HAPPY FOR TWENTY- IN TERMS OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE-
COALITION IS ASKING FOR OUR- I
JUST HEARD ABOUT THOSE TODAY WE
WILL DEFINITELY LOOK AT THEM
ALONG WITH- A CCI A AND DECIDE.
WHAT WE WILL DO- I THINK SOME OF
THESE DEFINITELY WE COULD ACCEPT
AND WE JUST JUST NEED TIME TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THEM AND WE WERE
VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REALLY CARES
ABOUT CHILDREN AND- BELIEVE ME
WE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWING PEOPLE
UNDER TWENTY ONE TO SMOKE.
ABSOLUTELY OUR AND THAT'S THAT.
I FEEL THAT MY HEART SO WHEN THE
TIME COMES I HOPE TO GET A
MOTION AND A MAJORITY VOTE TO
AND- WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER CORK FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH. MISTER WOULD YOU BE
READY TO GO.
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RESEARCHER AND
COLLEAGUES THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO TO HELP
RECOGNIZE ELECTION DAY AS A
HOLIDAY TO ENCOURAGE AS MUCH
CIVIC PARTICIPATION AS POSSIBLE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
HAVE DISH NO WITNESSES FOR
TECHNICAL ANSWERS IN CASE WE
NEED THEM. RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. IF THEY GIVE US LOW-
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES IF YOU'D
LIKE TO USE THEM- YOU YOU MAY
PROCEED. KRISTOFF MEYER WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS
MEASURE AND WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ANY. AND
IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION. ANY
OPPOSED TO SPEAK TODAY. A
MODERATOR TO GO TO THE PHONES
AND ON ANY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WHO WITNESSES BEGINNING WITH
SUPPORT AND THAT'S AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND ADDITIONALLY.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
A BI EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A LINE WITH AN OPERATOR- BE
JUST A MOMENT. OUR FIRST OF TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS LINE FORTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BILLY CONTACT
WITH CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE FORTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO. THANK YOU KNOW WATER LINES
IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY MISTER MODERATOR
ANY. OPPOSITION ON THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO ABE A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AND LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE A LINE
WITH AN OPERATOR. LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MELISSA HIDE
IT ON BEHALF OF THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT JUST
CALLING ON THAT NIGHT THANK YOU
. NO MIND THANK YOU FOR
OPPOSITION. THANK OU I THINK WE
HAVE A COMMON TOUGH FOR MORE FOR
ALL THE IN BAKERSFIELD. THANK
RICHARD LANCASTER LOW FOR
CONTINUING TO BRING THIS MEASURE
FOR DATA WE VOTED ON IT A NUMBER
OF TIMES I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WAS ADDED AS A- CO
AUTHOR. AND APPRECIATE YOU
CONTINUING TO BRING THIS BACK
BECAUSE I THINK IT ONLY
STRENGTHENS DEMOCRACY BY
PROVIDING MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE. THANK YOU
. WE WERE OPERATING AS
OPPORTUNITY BUT WE APPRECIATE
THAT ONE MORE I THINK. WITH
THANK YOU- A MISSILE YOU WELCOME
TO CLOSE ON THE BILL I ALSO
WOULD ASK RESPECTFULLY THAT
COULD BE COOL OTHER YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND APPRECIATE THE
- PASSION TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE ELECTION AS A HOLIDAY AS
YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS A- A
NUMBER OF FEDERAL PROPOSALS.
INCLUDING FROM THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF TO HELP ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO A DOCTOR
SIERRA RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
LIMIT. REACHED A QUORUM. THANK
YOU MR MUCH APPRECIATED. MISTER
CHOI READY. THANK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON SYSTEM THANK YOU
CHAIR AND ALL THE MEMBERS. AB A
PONY IS A THE SIXTY EIGHT THAT
IMPLEMENTS OF THE WE LOVE UP
CALIFORNIA BORDERS AS EXPRESSED
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH THE
PASSAGE OF A PROP SEVEN TO STOP
US REACHING THE CLOCK OUT TWICE
A YEAR AND THE PUT CALIFORNIA ON
PERMANENT DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIME
. SWITCHING OUR CLOCKS SO TWICE
A YEAR IS ON NOW OUTDATED THE
PRACTICE OF THAT IS A HAS OF
THOSE SO TO OUR HEALTH AND THE
WELL BEING AND THAT IS OUR TIME
TO END. WHEN NOT SPRING FORWARD
US- SOME OF TIME BEGAN- MY
DOCTOR SUN TOLD ME ALL OF THAT'S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF LAW- HEART
ATTACKS AND THE OLD RECALL
ISSUES. A PERMANENT A DAYLIGHT
SAVINGS TIME OUT WITH THE RESULT
IN OUR PRODUCTION ABOUT TRAFFIC
ACCIDENTS AND NO ROBBERIES SO
OFTEN THAT THE ENERGY SAVINGS TO
AND THE SUPPORTS OF TOURISM AND
THUS MORE BUSINESSES WHICH WE
ALL KNOW IS A NEEDED- AS WE
RECOVER FROM CORPORATE
NINETEENTH AND THAT MAKE. THERE
ARE ALSO SEVENTEEN OF THOSE
STATES THAT HAVE A PASSED A
LEGISLATION TO GIVE DAYLIGHT
SAVINGS TIME PERMANENT THAT AND
ARE WAITING FOR FEDERAL
APPROVAL. NOT A SINGLE STATE
THAT HAS INTRODUCED A-
LEGISLATION NOT TO MAKE A
STANDARD TIME. THE NEW PAMAN ON
TIME. THIS BILL I MAY ALSO LOOK
FAMILIAR TO YOU A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT IS SAW RE
INTRODUCTION OF WHAT A. B. SEVEN
ALSO THE BY. OUR KANSEN CHU
FORMER COLLEAGUE WHICH EVERYONE
HERE BOARDED UP FOR IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT IS ALSO A CONFORM IN
CONFORMITY WITH THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION THAT IS HOW
CURRENTLY PENDING CONGRESS- AND
THE PAST UP OUT OF A U. S. THE
SENATE THAT WHICH HE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. BUT WE
CANNOT THE RELY ON THE CONGRESO
TO ACT UP. A. B. TWENTY A SIXTY
EIGHT IS A CITY NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT WE LEVEL VOTERS TO
IN CALIFORNIA IS- ENACTED. AB
TWENTY A SIXTY EIGHT THAT HAS TO
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THE FROM
CALIFORNIA'S. STATEWIDE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND-%
HERE WITH ME THE TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS A
ELIGIBLE FOR THE GRAHAM-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIORENZA AND THE
PLANS. OF CONVENIENCE OUR
ALLIANCE. ELIZABETH THANK YOU
MAY GRAHAM WOULD YOU BE KIND
ENOUGH TO JUST ALLOW ME TO SET A
QUORUM AND I VERIFIED VOEPEL- TO
INTERRUPT THAT- MANCHESTER. A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THANK YOU
MISTER CHOI FOR YEAR ALLOWING US
TO DO THIS. YEAH ON THE QUORUM
SANTIAGO HI. CHOI YEAH
AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN. COOPER
DOLLY. DALY DAVIES GARCIA GIPSON
. JONES SAWYER. LACKEY LOW.
MATHIS QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS RIVAS
RUBIO. SALAS SMITH WE HAVE A
QUORUM. MISS GRAHAM THANK YOU
FOR BEING KIND AND PATIENT YOU
MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU. I'M I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FUSING AMOENUS ALLIANCE AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT. CFC IS A PREMIER
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THE INDEPENDENT
WHOLESALE AND RETAIL MARKETERS
OF GASOLINE DIESEL LUBRICATING
OIL AND PETROLEUM PRODUCTS. WE
ALSO REPRESENT THE TRANSPORTERS
OF THOSE PRODUCTS AND RETAIL
CONVENIENCE STORES. WE REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE SMALL BUSINESSES. THEY
WOULD BENEFIT FROM AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
MAKE DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIME
PERMANENT CALIFORNIA- I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT DAYLIGHT LONGER
IN THE EVENING MEANS PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO GO OUT SHOP MORE SAFELY
FILL UP THE GAS STATIONS. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE ENERGY COSTS
CONTINUE TO RISE IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
NATURAL DAYLIGHT LATER INTO THE
EVENING REDUCES ENERGY
CONSUMPTION AND PUTS RELIEF ON
OUR ELECTRICAL GRID ESPECIALLY
IN THE HOT SUMMERS. WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY SIXTY
EIGHT. THINGS CHOI IS AN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SUPPORT. I
DON'T SEE ONE BUT I ALONE
ASSUME- ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE HERE
SPEAKING ABOUT. YES YOU YOU MAY
PROCEED SIR. YES AND IF THE
COURT ACOSTA A YOU GET TWO
MINUTES. HE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU- I WOULD ENOUGH. YES A
VERY VERY GOOD I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE MUCH ÁP I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NONPROFIT SAFE
STANDARD TIME. THANK YOU. I'LL
BEGIN AGAIN- THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE MY NAME IS J. P.
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NONPROFIT SAVE CENTER TIME WERE
A FIVE ONE C. FOR. OPERATING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND I LIVE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE WORK WITH
DOCTORS TEACHERS SCIENTISTS
RELIGIOUS LEADERS COMMUNITY
LEADERS. CONCERNED PARENTS WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO PERMANENT
DAYLIGHT TIME AND IN SUPPORT AND
SUPPORT INSTEAD OF PERMANENT
STANDARD TIME. A PERMANENT
STANDARD TIME IS THE NATURAL
TIME TO FIND FROM THE SUN OR ITS
PERMANENT DAYLIGHT TIME IS
DESIGNED TO FORCE US TO WAKE
EARLIER TO INCREASE SPENDING IN
THE EVENING AND THAT'S NOT THE
RIGHT PRIORITY FOR A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE. AN ISSUE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY IF YOU WERE TO ASK MOST
CONSTITUENTS DO WE WANT TO SET
OUR ALARM CLOCKS AN HOUR EARLY
IN THE WINTER AND WAKE AND GO TO
WORK AND SCHOOL IN THE DARK THEY
WOULD SAY NO. BUT THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD FORCE THEM TO DO
THE LAST TIME THIS WAS TRIED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR IT
RESULTED IN SEVERAL DEATHS OF
CHILDREN. HERE IS A PHOTOGRAPH
OF CHILDREN WAITING FOR THE
SCHOOL BUS IN THE DARK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR IN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A
PHOTOGRAPH SHOWING HOW. SEVEN
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING WOULD
LOOK- UNDER PERMANENT DAYLIGHT
TIME IT WOULD BE COMPLETELY
DARK. WOULD BE EVEN WORSE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THIS POLICY
IS OPPOSED BY THE NATIONAL
SAFETY COUNCIL. THE CALIFORNIA
SLEEP SOCIETY THE NATIONAL PTA.
MANY MANY GROUPS FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY IT WOULD NOT SAVE ENERGY
IT IS NOT EVEN PERMITTED BY
FEDERAL LAW IF YOU WANT TO. MEET
THE VOTERS SAID DEMAND TO AND
CLOCK CHANGE THE ONLY WAY TO DO
THAT IS BY PERMANENT STANDARD
TIME. AS ARIZONA HAWAII AND ALL
FIVE TERRITORIES HAVE DONE THAT
IS WHAT IS FEDERALLY PRE
APPROVED THAT IS THE QUICKEST
SAFEST AND HEALTHIEST AND TO
CLOCK CHANGE. I WOULD NOT SAVE
ENERGY EITHER BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE WAKING PEOPLE UP EARLIER
IN THE MORNING THEY'RE RUNNING
THEIR HEAT WHICH CONSUMES MORE
ENERGY. THAN THE LIGHTING A
SAVINGS IN THE EVENING- SO I
ASKED FOR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AND RECOMMENDED A
RECOMMENDATION THAT IT BE
AMENDED PLEASE TO STANDARD TIME
ANDI'M GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO BE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED I. ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION. WITNESSES IN ROOM.
CNN WILL GO TO THE PHONES AT A
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF PHONE
BEGINNING WITH SUPPORT. KEEP OUT
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A LINE WITH AN OPERATOR.
FOR THOSE WHO EXPECT TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION PLEASE BE READY. WHAT
ARE THE FIRST LINE THIRTY TWO.
YES HI CAN YOU HEAR ME OK. YES
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITIONALLY
PLEASE. YES YOUNG CHRISTIAN
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIA OPPOSITION
OPPOSED. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE IN IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO A PROPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NO
OTHER LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
MEMBERS AS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE-
MISTREATED YOU'RE WELCOME TO
CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU OF THE
OPPOSITION- STATEMENT THERE'S A
TO MAKE A STANDARD TIME AS A
PERMANENT TIME- HOWEVER AN ISSUE
AS I EXPRESSED WHY LOCAL
SEVENTEEN OR THE STATE'S. HAVE
ADOPTED THE- A LOT SAVINGS TIME
AS A THE A PERMANENT- THE TIME
AND THEN ALSO YOU S. THE SENATE
HAS ABOUT THE HAS PASSED THE LAW
SAVINGS TIME IS A PERMANENT TIME
WAITING FOR THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES APPROVAL WHICH
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN IT'S GONNA
TAKE PLACE. BUT THERE'S A GREAT
. IF WE MAKE A CALIFORNIA ALONE
AS A STAND OF TIME PERMANENT
TIME. UP FEATHER GOVERNMENT THE
MAY DENY IT THAT BECAUSE THAT
US- NATIONAL TREND AND THE
PREFERENCE. TO MAKE A DAYLIGHT
SAVINGS TIME IS A PERMANENT TIME
SOLO ARTIST WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
BE ARE ARE ARE DOING IS SUCH
JOINING THE NATIONAL MOVE AND
THE PAPERS OF PREFERENCES SO
FROM MANY MANY OF THOSE STATES-
AND THEN ALSO. CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
ARE CITIZENS A PREFERENCE UP.
SWITCH INTO ONE PAYMENT TIME AND
THAT THIS WILL MAKE THEIR LIFE-
A LOT OF US ARE SIMPLER AND MORE
CONVENIENT. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE I'VE WORKED. THANK YOU WITH
THE PERSON. THE FIRST SEMESTER
LOW HAS TAKEN. MISMATCH ANOSOV
AND- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I AM ELEVEN AB TWO
EIGHT SIX EIGHT CHOI THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES AND
ENERGY SANTIAGO I CHOI AYE.
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN BRIAN COOPER
DOLLY DALY DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES AYE GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER I
LACKING. LOW LOW AYE MATHIS
MATHIS III QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS
RIVAS RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH SMITH I. WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO PASS WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN IN THE INTEREST OF MOVING
THIS VERY A LITTLE BIT QUICKER
I'M OUT FOR A SECOND MR LOS FEC
ANSARI CHRISTMAS LOW SECOND
MISTER BURN FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. I HAVE THE CRITICAL
ROLE THANK YOU. AND THE BILLS
ARE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR A.
B. TWENTY TWELVE A. B. TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE AM AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY ONE NINE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO AYE CHOI. CHOI I
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN BERMAN I
BRIAN. COOPER COOPER AYE DOLLY
DALY DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES AYE
GARCIA GIPSON. GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I A LACKEY
LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS MATHIS II
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS. RIVAS RUBIO.
RUBIO I SALAS SALAS I SMITH IF I
. ONE SECOND MISTER NAZARIAN- WE
WILL FOR A B. TWENTY TWO- TEN OF
THE FIRST MISSES ALL THE SECOND
MISTER BERMAN. MASSACRE PLEASE
KALRA. TWENTY TWO EVEN
ATTENTIVENESS COURT OKAY. OKAY
DO PRESENT A PROBLEM AT ALL LET
ME SAY THIS LET ME ASK FOR- LET
ME ASK FOR FIRST AND SECOND FROM
EIGHT FOUR AB TWENTY TWO TEN
FROM SUPPORT. OKAY MISTER MISTER
COOPER MR BERMAN. FILE ITEM ONE
AB TWENTY TWO TEN CORK THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO
AYE CHOI NO. JOIN NO
AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN BERMAN I
BRIAN COOLEY COOPER. COOPER AYE
DOLLY DALY DALY AYE DAVIES.
DAVIES NO GARCIA GIPSON GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY. LOW. MATHIS
QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS RIVAS. RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS. SALAS KNOW
SMITH. SMITH NO. AND UNLESS ONE
MISTER NAZARIAN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR KINDNESS AND PATIENCE ARE
WE THE FIRST THE SECOND FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO MR LOW
LECTURE TODAY. MISTER SALAS
FIRST MR BERMAN SECOND. MANSA
CRITICAL ROLE. I DO NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO LOW THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE CHOI.
FOR NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN BERMAN I BRIAN. COOPER
COOPER AYE DOLLY DALY. DAVIES.
AB IS NOT VOTING GARCIA. GIPSON
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LOW. MATHIS.
MATHIS NO QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS
RIVAS. RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. SMITH NO THE MOVE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF NOT
MISTER NAZARIAN HIGH I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MISTER CHAIR. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THAT AS WELL I WILL KEEP IT
BRIEF. AB EIGHTEEN OH ONE
ESTABLISHES THE GENOCIDE
AWARENESS DAY AS A STATE HOLIDAY
WHICH WOULD OBSERVE WHICH WOULD
BE OBSERVED ANNUALLY ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH. AS A STATE
HOLIDAY ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS CS
USING COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD
BE REQUIRED WHILE UC'S WOULD BE
REQUESTED TO CLOSE DOWN. A
COLLEAGUES UNFORTUNATE GENOCIDE
HAS BEEN A REALITY THAT HAS
IMPACTED MANY COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE FOUND REFUGE AND SETTLED
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHETHER
IT BE. THE ARMENIAN SYRIAN
JEWISH UKRAINIAN OR CAMBODIAN
AMONG MANY OTHER COMMUNITIES. SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN- WE'RE NOT
I'M NOT GONNA ASK FOR SUPPORT-
PRESENTERS IN THE ROOM YOU GET
TWO MINUTES. FOR TWO PEOPLE IF
THERE'S ANY MAIN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM MISTER
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU FOR IT
POURED VERY. THANK YOU. I DON'T
SEE ANYONE UNLESS YOU'RE UNLESS
I'M I BELIEVE THERE WAS GOING TO
BE ONE ON THE PHONE OKAY AND
THAT'S THE MAIN THE MAIN SUPPORT
YES MISTER MODERATOR IF WE CAN
FIND THAT PERSON GIVEN NAME
MISTER NAZARIAN. HI THIS IS
ZAREEN OVERSEEING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF JEWISH WORLD WATCH-
WEREN'T ANTI GENOCIDE AND MASS
ATROCITIES NONPROFIT FOUNDED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR- OF THE
RESPONSE TO THE GENOCIDE IN
DARFUR. MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
YEARS LATER GENOCIDE AND MASS
ATROCITIES HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
PREVALENT. WITHIN OUR OWN
EXPERIENCES OF PERSECUTION
JEWISH TRADITION AND VALUES ARE
OBLIGATED TO ENSURE THAT NEVER
AGAIN IF INTEREST OF THE THRILL
FOR IT BUT A CALL TO ACTION. ON
BEHALF OF OUR SUPPORTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN THE COUNTRY I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PASS A
BEACH YOU KNOW WANT TO ESTABLISH
EQUAL TWENTY FOURTH IN GENOCIDE
AWARENESS DAY. THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE IF THE FIRST MODERN
GENOCIDE AND RECORD ALTHOUGH IT
TOOK A HUNDRED AND SIXTY YEARS.
TO RECOGNIZE GREAT BUT PROPERTY
RETREATED AGAINST THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE. MAYBE Y. UNPROVOKED
AGGRESSION AND THREATS FROM
TURKISH AND AZERBAIJANI LEADERS
CONTINUE TO BE A RAT REALITY FOR
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE TO THE FERRY
DAY. IT'S BEEN A ROAD MAP FOR
MANY ONGOING GENOCIDE
SITUACIONAL BOX COME BACK TODAY
WHETHER IT BE WEAKER THE
RODENSTOCK. OR ANY OTHERS ACROSS
THE WORLD. DENNIS I DENIAL OF
THEM IS MORE THAN A SIMPLE
DENIAL OF FACTS AND IT IS
PERPETUATED BY A LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE ON THE ISSUE. THIS CAN
RESULT IN THOSE RESPONSIBLY
AVOID ACCOUNTABILITY AND CREATE
THE FRAMEWORK FOR FUTURE
CONFLICT AND PERSECUTION BY
RAISING THE PAST. OPPRESSORS AND
EXTREMISTS ARE BETTER ABLE TO
FOMENT HATE AMONG I'M BE ON
WEDDING. PUBLIC IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN RABBI HAROLD CHAU LIFE
FOUNDER OF JEWISH WORLD WATCH
RECOGNIZING THE NINETY SECOND
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE THAT MEMORY IS AN
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENT TO DEVELOP
MORAL SENSIBILITY AND ME HAVE
THE PAST FLIGHTS IN THE FUTURE
TO DENY YESTERDAY TO FORGET
TOMORROW ANYTHING IN THE US.
TODAY COMMEMORATION IS MORE THAN
A LESSON IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK UNDER OF THE CALL OF
DANGEROUS AND HOW OTHERING
KIMBER SOCIETY IT IS A POWERFUL
TOOL TO ENGAGE PEOPLE ACROSS
GENERATIONS AND DISCUSSED THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS
THE NATURE AND THE IMPACT OF
ATROCITY CRIMES HOW TO PREVENT
THEM. THE MOST IMPORTANT. TO
PROVIDE NOT. THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
HEALING AND REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY WE STRONGLY
URGE THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY TO
QUICKLY PASS EIGHTY EIGHTEEN OH
ONE THANK YOU TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE SPREADING OUR COMMITMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGING THE ATROCITIES OF
THE PAST AND TO BETTER BE
PREPARED TO STAND AGAINST HATE
AND TARGETED PERSECUTION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK RIGHT NOW WE
GO TO ANY ANY MEMBERS IN THE
ROOM FOR ANY. REMEMBER THE
PUBLIC WOULD MEAN OPPOSITION
AGAINST. THEMEN WOULD EXPECT
NONE I HAVE A SO I WILL GO TO
THE PHONES AT THAT FOR ANY- OR
OPPOSITION AGAIN MAIN. OUR
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY-
MISTER MODERATOR. YOU TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN
THAT'S EIGHT ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. WE DO HAVE A
LINING Q. ME JUST A MOMENT FOR A.
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS ME
AROUND TOO MUCH IN THE ARMENIAN
ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA WE FULLY
SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN OH ONE.
NORTHERN ALLIANCE IN Q. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- AND WOULD
ASK YOU TO CLOSE IF YOU'D LIKE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE WOULD
NEED A FIRST OR SECOND- ALRIGHT
THANK YOU. MISTER SMITH MA'AM
THE CRITICAL ROLE. AB EIGHTEEN
OH ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
CHOI CHOICE I AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN BERMAN I BRIAN COOPER.
COOPER AYE DOLLY DALY. DALY AYE
DAVIES AYE DAVIES AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON. JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I LACKING. LACKEY I LOW
MATHIS MATHIS III QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS. RIVAS RUBIO. SALAS SALAS
I SMITH. SMITH I. WITH THE ROLE
OPEN AND WE'LL PROCEED TO MISTER
FLORA THANK YOU I THANK YOU
MISTER HAS EARNED. ON AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN. WELL FIRST- THAT
THE SENATE I'M SORRY. IN THE
BILL. THANK YOU JERRY MEMBERS-
I'LL MAKE THIS SUPER BRIEF AND I
APPRECIATE THE SECOND THE FIRST
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL VOTING LOCATIONS TO
CALIFORNIA VOTERS BY AUTHORIZING
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE
THE OPTION OF UTILIZING VENUES
THAT HAVE- BARS OR SELL ALCOHOL
TO THAT TO SERVE AS VOTING
LOCATIONS CALLING IN TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN ANSWERING
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS TRICIA WEBER
FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. AND IT
SHOULD CALPERS SOCIALLY OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER FLOOR WE APPRECIATE
YOUR BREVITY I. ANY MAIN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE BUILDING. I DON'T
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYTHING
SUPPORT WITNESSES NO JUST
ADDRESS WEBER ON THE PHONE OKAY
THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE. GET A- ASKING
CONSIDER TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
MISS WEBER YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE SANTIAGO ON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
TRICIA WEBER SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
CLERK REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AND
THE CO CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ITS
AND ITS STAFF FOR THEIR
IMPORTANT WORK ON THE BILL- IN
THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND FOR
ALL ELECTIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. INCLUDING THE SEPTEMBER
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL ELECTION.
COUNTIES WERE ALLOWED BY YOUR
LEGISLATURE TO TEMPER THE
TEMPORARY ABILITY TO USE VENUES
LIKE COMMUNITY CENTERS. VETERANS
CALLED BANQUET ROOMS AND
LOUNGES. LOCATIONS WE HAVE
AVOIDED APPROACHING IN THE PAST.
BECAUSE THESE FOLKS ARE ALSO
PLACES. AVERAGES ARE STILL. AB
TWENTY SEVEN WOULD MAKE THIS
TEMPORARY CHANGE PERMANENT
ALLOWING COUNTIES TO CONTINUE
USING THESE LOCATIONS GOING
FORWARD. FOR COUNTIES THAT WERE
ABLE TO UTILIZE THE TEMPORARY
LIFTING OF THE RESTRICTION THEY
HAVE FOUND THAT THEY WERE BETTER
ABLE TO HELP THE HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FOUR
POINT PLAY FACILITY OPTIONS ARE
OFTEN LIMITED. IT'S SURPRISING
TO THINK IN THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
BECOMING HARDER NOT EASIER FOR
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO FIND
SUITABLE POLLING PLACES OR VOTE
CENTERS FOR THEIR VOTERS.
HOWEVER BADLY IT IS COLDER LESS
INCLINED TO SERVE AS POLLING
PLACES BECAUSE OF SECURITY
CONCERNS. CHURCHES ARE REFUSING
TO OPEN AS BOTH CENTERS AND
RECORD NUMBERS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE POLARIZING POLITICAL
CLIMATE. SENIOR CENTERS ARE SAID
THAT- BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID OF
INDIAN ENDANGERINGTHEIR HEALTH
THE HEALTH OF THE COMMUNITY. BUT
PROP BOTH LOCATIONS AS
PARTICULAR DIFFICULT FOR VOTE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT COUNTY. YOU
MUST HAVE DISABILITIES OPEN FOR
FOUR OR ELEVEN DAYS IN A ROW.
HAVING THESE HOLDEN WATCHES
AVAILABLE AS BOTH CENTER SITE
HAS BEEN A PERFECT ALTERNATIVE
TO THOSE FACILITIES WHO ARE NOW
TELLING US NO WE ARE NO LONGER
AVAILABLE YEAH. HOW THANK CHECK
WITH THE PARKING PARKS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION EIGHTY COMPLIANCE
AND MORE IN ORDER TO PICK THE
RIGHT FACILITY FOR COMMUNITY AS
A POLLING PLACE ARE VOTE CENTER
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN WILL
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO USE SOME
FACILITIES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
HAVE ENJOYED USING FOR NEARLY
TWO YEARS NOW. I'M FINDING
WILLING TO FACILITIES HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY MORE DIFFICULT. WE
ARE AWARE OF THE CONCERNS
BROUGHT FORTH BY ALCOHOL JUSTICE
IN THEIR OPPOSITION.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE HAD A
PRODUCTIVE AND MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER CONVERSATION TO FIND
MORE COMMON GROUND AS THIS BILL
PROGRESSES. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
AND I'M AVAILABLE TO HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
MATURE A WILL GO TO BE MAIN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM WHO IS
ONE WHO IS WANTING TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL. AND AGAIN TWO MINUTES
. THANK YOU.
GERMAN SANTIAGO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESENT LIKE SECULAR
DIRECTOR ALCOHOL JUSTICE WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF SERIOUS CONCERNS
WITH THE NINETEEN ESTABLISHMENTS
WITH ALCOHOL LICENSES AS POLLING
PLACES AND WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- NO
VOTE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE SKIP ON BEHALF OF
KAPPA CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE WE TOO ARE IN
OPPOSITION BUT DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S- WILLINGNESS TO- WORK
THROUGH- THIS IS A SENSITIVE
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS BOTH OF YOU I DO
WE HAVE ANY MISTER MODERATE TO
HAVE ANY SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR
OPPOSITION STARTING SUPPORT. AND
AGAIN NAME INTO THIS ONLY. TO
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE OF THEM ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU. MISS FORTY MICHAEL OF THE
BILL IS RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. YES THIS IS ALSO. THANK YOU
THINK REST FOR APPRECIATE YOU
EXPANDING DEMOCRACY I THINK THIS
IS GOING TO HELP WORKS SPECIALLY
EXPANDED TO OUR VETERANS HALLS I
THINK THAT SAYS SOMETHING THAT'S
GONNA BE HELPFUL IN THE FUTURE
AND NO YOU SELECTED A LOT OF
HEAT FOR THIS BILL AND THAT'S
WHY IT WORK- BUT I FORGIVE YOU.
THANK BY THREE QUARTERS OF
ENOUGH EYES IS A COKE SO. IT'LL
BE OUR- NO I APPRECIATE THAT IN
ONE OF THE- BIG REASONS WHY WE
WANT TO TAKE THIS BILL ON WAS TO
ALLOW THE VETERANS HALLS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE BE VOTING SITES I
APPRECIATE THAT. VERY MUCH.
THANK AND APPRECIATE THE HUMOR.
MADAM SECRETARY WE'VE ALREADY
HAD A FIRST THE SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB ZERO THREE
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO AYE CHOI.
CHOI I AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN
BERMAN I BRIAN. COOPER COOPER
AYE DOLLY LEE DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES AYE GARCIA GIPSON GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY. LACKEY I LOW LOW AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I. QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS I RIVAS. RUBIO SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. THE BILL THE BILL
HAVE A BOTH BELIEVE THE ROLE OF
THANK YOU THANK YOU TERRY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MISTER WHAT.
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. WE ARE FIRST
MISTER LOHUD SECOND SALAS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE I'LL BE BRIEF I
HEARD MOTION YOUR SECOND BUT HE
DID HEAR MOTIONS OF BUT ANYWAY
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO START BY
TAKING THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PRETTY SIMPLE BILL.
FACTORS ARE ALLOWED TO OWN
RESTAURANT. ABOUT WHAT'S PEOPLE
ARE BY LA JOLLA RESTAURANTS BUT
BRIDGE IBM MANUFACTURES RIGHT
NOW. THEY'RE ALLOWED TO SELF
DISTRIBUTE THEIR OWN BEER TO
RESTAURANTS. BUT THEY AREN'T
ALLOWED TO SELF DISTRIBUTE THEIR
BEER TO THE RESTAURANTS THEY OWN
. THINK ABOUT THAT FOR SET. KERN
DYNAMIC GRAYSON ODD OUTCOME WERE
BREWERY CAN BRING ITS BEER TO
ANY RESTAURANT IN TOWN. BUT IF
THEY OWN THE RESTAURANT NEXT
DOOR THEY MUST USE A
DISTRIBUTOR. WILL FIRST TAKE THE
BEER TO A WAREHOUSE OFTEN IN
ANOTHER CITY YOU FOR BRING THE
BEER BACK TO THE RESTAURANT NEXT
DOOR. THE RESULTS IN ABU.
OBVIOUS INEFFICIENCIES AND
UNNECESSARY WILL UNNECESSARY
WASTEFUL TRANSPORTATION COSTS
GHG EMISSIONS. BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS BEER MANUFACTURERS TO
SELF DISTRIBUTE THEIR BEER TO
THE RESTAURANTS THEY ON. YOUR
TESTIFIED SUPPORT. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA GRAPHIC REFEREES
ASSOCIATION IS REJECT. THANK YOU
MISTER WOULDN'T YOU HAVE A WHO
YOU CAN HAVE UP TO TWO WITNESSES
WITH TWO MINUTES TO SUPPORT.
MA'AM YOU SPEAK THINK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M LORI AJAX
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION IN HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND CAN
MANY STAFF FOR WORKING TOGETHER
ON AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
ACCEPTABLE TO BOTH OF US IN THE
OPPOSITION AS AMENDED THIS BILL
ADDRESSES INEFFICIENCIES AND
SELF DISTRIBUTION OF BEER TO
REACH LICENSES THAT ARE OWNED BY
THE BREWERIES AS LONG AS IT'S
WITHIN A FIVE MILE RADIUS OF THE
PRODUCTION BREWERY. CCPA
RESPECT- YOUR SON AND I
APPRECIATE YOU ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL THANK. THANK YOU
ANOTHER MAIL TO US SUPPORT WHEN
THIS MR WOULD. I THINK WE'RE I
THINK WE'RE GOOD. THANK YOU
ACTUALLY WANT THANK YOU FOR A
FOR YOU YOUR STAFF ENGAGING TO
REALLY WORK HARD TO. THE
CONTRAPOSITION WERE MOST OF THE
OPPOSITION HAS. AS A BIGGER
TRUCK THANK YOU. FOR THAT. ANY
MAIN OPPOSITION HERE SPEAK- IN
THE ROOM. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON LUIS SANCHEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY BEER
DISTRIBUTORS THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO THE AUTHOR TO YOUR STAFF AND
TO THE SPONSORS WE ARE NOT
NEUTRAL WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIRMAN
SANTIAGO AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AGAIN COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'LL
CALL JUSTICE IS. A DRUG. LET ME
START OVER AGAIN. ALCOHOL
JUSTICE IS THE ALCOHOL AND OTHER
DRUGS INDUSTRY WATCHDOG IN SAN
RAFAEL. CALIFORNIA WE ADVOCATE
FOR EVIDENCE BASED POLICIES THAT
PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
. WE ARE WRITING TO EXPRESS AN
OBVIOUSLY HERE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE OH
ONE. WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL
IS AN EFFORT TO PATCH. THE
STRANGE APPLICATION. OF LAW
PERTAINING TO KERN ALCOHOL
MANUFACTURE PRIVILEGES THE
PROBLEM ORIGINATES WITH STANDING
LAW EFFECT OF UNDERMINING TIED
HOUSE AND THREE DEREGULATION'S.
IT IS STRANGE FOR MANUFACTURED
TO NOT BE ABLE TO DELIVER THEIR
OWN PRODUCT TO THEIR OWN ON SALE
LICENSE IT IS STRANGER FOR
MANUFACTURED. TO OWN A BILL
LICENSE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
PLEASE RESPECT THE INTENT OF THE
THREE TIER UNTIED HOUSE
REGULATIONS TO PREVENT. AND
THESE BUSINESS PRACTICES WHILE
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY WE ASK PLEASE VOTE NO ON
THIS AB TWENTY THREE OH ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A
COMMENT IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION HERE SPEAK. S. C.
NUMBER GO TO PHONES MISTER
MODERATOR AS ANY SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AGAIN NAME.
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY.
KEEP TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE OH
ON PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S A
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. LINE
THIRTY SIX IF YOU WANTD TO.
MAKE A COMMENT THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THAT IS SO
CRITICAL PREPARE BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTORS WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF. AND
HIS STAFF AND COULD YOU SPELL
WORKING HARD TO MAKE THIS SO
BILLS A SUCCESSFUL WE REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU KNOW
ADELINE SECURE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. CNN MISTER WOULD
YOU MICHAEL OF CLOSING THE BILL
THAT WE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THIS-
BILL DOES ENJOY A FIRST. WE
DON'T HAVE THE FIRST SO- WE DO
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT. I'M NOT
SECURE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
TWENTY THREE OH ONE THE MOTION
IS DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE CHOI
AYE CHOI AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN BERMAN I BRIAN BRIAN I
COOPER COOPER AYE DOLLY. DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES AYE
GARCIA GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
LACKEY I LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS
MATHIS I. QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS
RAMOS I REVISED. RUBIO SALAS
SALAS I SMITH SMITH I. THE BILL
HAS BEEN OPPOSED TO PASS WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN AND MISTER BERMAN
YOU'RE UP TO BAT. YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JR AND
COLLEAGUES ARE LIKE A START BY
THINKING THE COMMITTEES
CONSULTANT FOR HIS ENGAGEMENT
AND THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS
IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE. IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERIES FIND
THEMSELVES COMPETING IN A GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE FOR CONSUMER
AWARENESS AND POPULARITY.
TASTING ROOMS WILL LOOK AT
LICENSES ARE A PRIMARY MEANS FOR
CRAFT BREWERIES TO INCREASE
BRAND RECOGNITION. AND CONSUMER
FOLLOWING. THE CURRENT LIMIT. OF
SIXTY DUPLICATE LICENSES WAS SET
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN A
NUMBER DEEMED REASONABLE AT THE
TIME. THE SAME LEGISLATION
FURTHER LIMITED A BREWER'S
ABILITY TO SERVE FOOD AT ONLY
TWO OUT OF THE SIX SATELLITE
LOCATIONS. IN THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS THE MARKET HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY AND THE NUMBER OF.
DOT IF FOR SOME FIRST THE SALE
OF FOOD ON SITE UNDER THIS
PROVISION OF LAW BECAME A
CRUCIAL FACTOR IN DETERMINING IF
OR WHEN THE BUSINESSES WERE ABLE
TO REOPEN AS WE BEGAN TO
INITIALLY EMERGE FROM THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AS PROPOSED TO
BE AMENDED THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
AN INCREMENTAL CHANGE ALONG THE
NUMBER OF DUPLICATE LICENSES TO
GROW FROM SIX TO EIGHT AND THE
NUMBER OF THOSE THAT CAN BE USED
FOR BONAFIDE EATING
ESTABLISHMENTS FROM TWO TO FOUR.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME TO.
FIND SUPPORT IS LORI AJAX
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION. EGGMAN EXECUTIVE
PROCEED IT AFTERNOON AGAINST MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M LORI AJAX THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION AND HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING TOGETHER ON
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
ACCEPTABLE TO BOTH US AND THE
OPPOSITION. AS AMENDED THIS BILL
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE NEEDS OF
OUR BREWERY MEMBERS TO CONTINUE
TO SUCCEED AND GROW IN THE STATE
IN ORDER TO REMAIN STRONG
EMPLOYERS IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. CCA RESPECTFULLY
DOES YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BIGAMIST REMITTED THE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES.
THEY BROUGHT. NO SIR THANK YOU
ANY. OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM. MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSONALLY
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY BEER
DISTRIBUTORS THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR THE SPONSORS IN YOUR
OFFICE ON YOURS COMMITTEE STAFF
WE ARE NOW AT A NEWS WITH THE
NEW AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN DETERMINED
SANTIAGO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND RESPECTFULLY- WE OPPOSE THIS
AB TWENTY THREE OH SEVEN-
SEVILLA. ALCOHOL JUSTICE THE
INTO OF THREE TO IN TIGHT HOUSE
LAWS TO RESTRICT THE OF OUR MENU
TO ESTABLISH MY POLICIES WHICH
RESULT IN END TAKEN PRACTICES AS
AS IN TO PROMOTE CA. AND UNDER
PUBLIC CAL AND SAFE. THE
EXPANSION OF ON SALE. THE RETAIL
PRIVILEGES TO MANUFACTURERS
ESPECIALLY WHEN COMBINED WITH AB
TWENTY THREE OH ONES EFFORT TO
ENTIRELY ELIMINATE WHOLESALERS
FROM A VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
ALCOHOL MANUFACTURER THREATENS
TO EXPAND SIX FOLD. THE
MANUFACTURING LICENSES WE
FORESEE THE FOLLOWING CONCERNS.
WHICH WE ADDRESS IN OUR LETTER
SO KEEP IT SHORT BUT ONCE AGAIN
. PLEASE RESPECT THE INTENT OF
THIS THREE TIER AND- TIED HOUSE
REGULATIONS TO PREVENT MONOPOLY
AND THE ANTI COMPETITIVE
BUSINESS PRACTICES WHILE
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY WE S. FINALLY FOR YOU TO
VOTE NO ON AB TWENTY THREE OH
SEVEN. THANK YOU- FINO
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION. WITNESSES
HERE THE PRESENT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO- ONLINE PHONES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- MISTER MODERATOR
. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY
THREE OH SEVEN ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE THIRTY SIX. I'M
SORRY THIRTY SIX PREVIOUS PRESS
THE BUTTONS AGAIN THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BEER AND BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS
WE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU UP HERE IN THE STAFF WILL
CONVINCE. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. S. THANK YOU ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NOT SEEN
ANY- IS REMOTELY LIKE CLOTHES
RESPECT RESPECT FASTER AGO DID I
HEAR A MR OF BRIAN DID WE JUST
BEAT HIM IN A MOTION COMMON YEAH
AND I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE SEAT.
THERE IT IS THANK YOU VERY-
MADAM SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALL YOU HAVE SECOND I
APOLOGIZE I. THOUGHT I GOT AHEAD
OF MYSELF HERE. AB TWENTY THREE
OH SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SOMETHING I WON'T AYE SANTIAGO
AYE CHOI HI CHOI I AGUIAR-CURRY
. BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE BRIAN
BRIAN I COOPER COOPER AYE DOLLY
. DALY DALY AYE DAVIES AYE
DAVIES AYE GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY I LO LO AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I. QUIRK-SILVA.
RAMOS RAMOS IDEA OF US. THREE OF
US I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH SMITH I. A BILL A
COUPLE COULD PASS WILL LEAVE THE
- LEAVE IT OPEN- MISTER REVISED
. THE CUT YOU'RE READY FOR WE
GOT WE APPRECIATE. WHERE A
PERSON HAS TO GET THE SECOND FOR
MR BERMAN AND MR SALAS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES
IS THAT THIS LEGISLATION IS
ILLEGAL ONE SEVEN FOUR TWO I
SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE
RECEIVES ALL MONEY IT IS OWED BY
TOBACCO COMPANIES AND PREVENT
NON FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES FROM
ENTERING THE MARKET. THE TOBACCO
MASTER SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
PROVIDES FOR SUBSTANTIAL ANNUAL
PAYMENTS FROM TOBACCO
MANUFACTURERS TO CALIFORNIA IN
PERPETUITY WHICH HAVE EXCEEDED A
HUNDRED MILLION IN RECENT YEARS
HOWEVER THESE PAYMENTS ARE
DEPENDENT ON THE DILIGENT
ENFORCEMENT OF AN ESCROW STATUTE
THAT IMPOSES FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS ON TOBACCO
COMPANIES. THAT ARE NOT PART OF
THE MASTER SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
. TO ENSURE THAT WE PREVENT THE
STATE FROM LOSING OUT ON ANY
PAYMENTS THIS BILL STRENGTHENS
EXISTING LAW TO AID. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE- AND
THEREFORE SPENT OF THAT ESCROW
STATUTE AND OTHER MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT OBLIGATIONS
BY TARGETING NON COMPLIANT BAD
ACTORS. MEANWHILE THE FIRE
SAFETY ACT PROHIBITS CIGARETTES
FROM BEING SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
UNLESS THEY MEET FIRE SAFETY
STANDARDS. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL REVIEW
CIGARETTES TO VERIFY FIRE
SAFETY. HOWEVER DUE TO CERTAIN
RESTRAINTS MANY CIGARETTES HAVE
BEEN AUTOMAT. PROVED WHICH- IS
WHEN THE FIRE MARSHAL TAKES NO
ACTION ON CIGARETTE APPLICATIONS
AFTER TEN DAYS. SO THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP REDUCE THE
RISK OF POTENTIAL WILDFIRE.
ABOUT TRANSFER YOU FORCE MEANT.
ACT GOES OFF WHICH FORCES OTHER
PARTS OF THE PARK SAFETY ACT AND
EXTENDS THE FIRE SAFETY REVIEW
PERIOD FROM TEN DAYS TO THIRTY.
A TO PROVIDE INTERCHANGEABLE AND
WHAT TIME TO THAT FIRE SAFETY
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY ARE JANA
STANFORD AND JAMES HART ON
BEHALF OF THE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. A. N.
WE MAY BEGIN WITH THOSE IN AND
SUPPORT TWO MINUTES EACH A
RECOMMEND THANK YOU. THERE BY
PHONE OR HERE I'VE I DON'T KNOW
NOTIFY DO YOU MIND IF I GO TO
THE OPERA JACKETS ARE HERE AND
THEN WE'LL CATCH UP WITH THEM-
ANY MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE
MAY BEGIN NOW FOR TWO MINUTES.
EACH I DON'T SEE ANY. BY
SOMETIME AGO TO THE PHONE RIGHT
. ALSO WILL GO TO A LITTLE BIT.
A TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE ON
THE PHONE MISTER OKAY PERFECT-
IF WE CAN HAVE THEM START NOW.
YOUR CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JANET STANFORD AND
I'M THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE NEED
TWENTY FINAL TOPIC. ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE IMPROPER IN
ITSELF. IT SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO.
BILL THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO MEET ITS
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE TOBACCO
MASTER SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. AND
DILIGENTLY ENFORCE THE STATE
ACOLYTES. DETERMINATION THE
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT SATISFIED ARE
ENFORCEMENT OBLIGATIONS COULD
RISK THE LOSS OF A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE ANNUAL SETTLEMENT
PAYMENTS THAT CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED. WHICH AS A FAMILY
MEMBER RIVAS MENTION HAVE
RECENTLY EXCEEDED EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR. THE
THAT BUSINESS NOT ONLY THE SAME
OVER TIME AB SEVENTY FORTY TWO
WHAT AT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
TOBACCO DIRECTORY STATUTE TO
ADDRESS RECENT DEVELOPMENTS IN
THE CIGARETTE INDUSTRY. INDEED
IMPORTANT EFFORT. THE GOOD
GOVERNANCE MEASURE THAT PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INTEREST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND MAINTAIN THE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR COMPLIANCE A
GREAT MANUFACTURERS. THAT THE
ALSO IMPROVES EFFICIENCY BY
CONSOLIDATING ADMINISTRATION AND
ENFORCEMENT OF THE FIRE SAFE
CIGARETTE PROGRAM WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. I THINK THE
GRAPHICS ENGLISH WHEN THEY'RE
NOT BEING ACTIVELY SMOKED ONE ON
FIRE STICK I HAD NON FIRE SAFE
CIGARETTES DONOT GO OUT ON
THEIR OWN THAT'S PRESENTING A
SERIOUS FIRE RISK. DETAINEES ON
OFFICE RT REVIEWS THE VOTE.
VERIFICATION FIVE. FIVE MANY
FACTS EACH. IT FORTY TWO REDUCES
THE COST I CAN TELL. THE I THINK
. DOWN FOR TO AGENCIES TO Y.
TWENTY TWENTY THE BILL BEFORE
YOU PACK IN THE THAT STOCK FOR
YOU TO COOK YOUR TIME CONSTRAINT
. THE THEORY HOPE TO GET THIS
OVER THE FINISH TO AND THE CAL
CAN I CAN TO RECEIVE THE FAN
ANNUAL PAIN UNDER THE MASTER
THOUGHT AGREEMENT. GOING ON THE
TODAY IS JAMES THE PROVIDE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY IN OUR HOW CARE
RIGHT ACCESS WHOSE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY THEY MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION
MEMBERS AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
THOUGHT. THANK YOU. A I'M GONNA
MOVE THE- MAY NOT BE. YEAH I
JUST ASKING AGAIN- I KNOW WENT
THROUGH BEFORE BUT JUST CASE I
MISS THEM ON THE PHONE. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO JUST
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. GOING
BACK TO THE MODERATOR. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE SEVEN FOUR TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN
ZERO. WELL THE LINE SIXTY FOUR.
HELLO TURN MEMBERS CAROLINE KERN
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO THANK
YOU. NO FOR LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME- ANY COMMITMENT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE MYSTERY BUT YOU
MAY CLOSE ON THE BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I'VE ALWAYS
CHAD THANK YOU WE ALREADY HAVE A
FIRST SECOND AND A THIRD- MEMSIC
TRIP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY SANTIAGO AYE
SANTIAGO AYE CHOI. WHY NOT
VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BERMAN BERMAN I BRIAN BRIAN
I COOPER COOPER AYE DOLLY. DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES. DAVIES NO
GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
. LIKE YOU KNOW LOW. LOW AYE
MATHIS MATHIS NO QUIRK-SILVA.
RAMOS THOMAS AYE RIVAS RIVAS AYE
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
SMITH. WITH NO. THE BILL HAS THE
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR A
FOR MEMBERS TOADD ON. THAT
INCLUDES A BILL GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP FOR A
MEMBERS CAN ADD ON. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUILAR CURRY HI BRIAN. BRIAN I
COOPER- DOLLY. GARCIA
QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS. RAMOS I
THREE OF US THREE OF US I THINK
. IF I COUNTED UP. AB TWENTY TWO
TEN CORK. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I BRIAN BRIAN I.
DOLLY. ON THE CONSENT COUNTY- I
AM S. LIKE IN ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GARCIA. LACKEY. AB.
TWENTY TWO TEN. LACKEY I LOW LOW
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NOT VOTING
QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS RAMOS I
REQUEST. RIVAS I. THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH TO KEEP IT WILL GO ONE
MORE CIRCLE AROUND. AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY TWO RIVAS. DOLLY GARCIA.
QUIRK-SILVA. A. B. EIGHTEEN OH
ONE AND IS ARIAN AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY HI BRIAN. BRIAN HI
DOLLY. GARCIA GIPSON GIPSON I
LOW. LOW I QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS
RAMOS I RIVAS RIVAS AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
HELLO AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
I BRIAN. BRIAN I DOLLY. DALY.
GARCIA LACKING. LACKEY NO LOW.
LOW I QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS. RAMOS
IT OF US. RIVAS I. HAS ENUGH
WITH IT OPEN THE BILL HAS NOT
BELIEVE OPEN. RIGHT MISTER
GIBSON ADDED IS VERY BILL.
WE'RE STILL GOING THROUGH A FEW
OTHER BILLS- FOLKS. WE JUST.
BUT IT. GLOBAL TO PROCEED TO THE
REST OF THEM THAT OUTSTANDING
ANIMAL WILL JUST RUN TO REMEMBER
COULD. TWO ZERO THREE SEVEN
FLORA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
BRIAN. BRIAN I DOLLY. GARCIA
QUIRK-SILVA. RIVAS RIVAS I'D
RUBIO. RUBIO I. THAT'S ENOUGH
WITH. YOUR AVAILABLE TO LEAVE IT
OPEN. TWENTY THREE OH ONE WOOD
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I. DOLLY GARCIA
QUIRK-SILVA. RIVAS RIVAS I'D
RUBIO RUBIO I ONE OF THE- BILL
HAS ROUGHLY BILL FOR MOGO. TWO
EIGHT SIX EIGHT CHOI THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEES
ON UTILITIES AND ENERGY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BRIAN. BRIAN NOT VOTING DOLLY.
GARCIA LACKING. LACKEY I
QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS RAMOS I'D
RIVAS RIVAS I ASSEMBLY COMMITTED
A BILL HAVE ENOUGH AVAILABLE
OPEN- FOR ONE MARGOT THE LAST
ONE- COUNTY SEVENTEEN. AB TWENTY
THREE OH SEVEN BERMAN THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
DOLLY GARCIA QUIRK-SILVA. WE'LL
HAVE A NOT A BILL AS THE VOTE TO
LEAVE IT OPEN.
HI I.
YEAH.
WELL.
RIGHT.
OKAY YEAH QUIRK-SILVA ON THE
QUORUM. CONSENT CALENDAR. HI. AB
TWENTY TWO TEN QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I. AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY TWO QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I. AB EIGHTEEN OH
ONE QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA I.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA EINMAL
. AB TWO ZERO THREE SEVEN
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA I. AB
TWENTY THREE OH ONE QUIRK-SILVA
. QUIRK-SILVA I'M- AB TWENTY
THREE OH SEVEN QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I'M AB TWO EIGHT SIX
EIGHT QUIRK-SILVA. ABOUT. FIVE
WITHOUT. YEAH.
YEAH.
THAT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR DOLLY.
DOLLY I THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
TWENTY IT IS OUT. AB TWENTY TWO
TEN DOLLY. ALI NOT VOTING AT
MEASURE IS OUT WITH FOURTEEN. AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO DOLLY. DOLLY
I THAT MEASURE IS OUT WITH
FIFTEEN. AB EIGHTEEN NO ONE
DOLLY. ALI I THAT MEASURE IS OUT
WITH TWENTY. AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO DOLLY. NO THAT MEASURE IS
OUT WITH THIRTEEN. AB TWO ZERO
THREE SEVEN DOLLY. DOLLY I THAT
MEASURE IS OUT WITH TWENTY. AB
TWENTY THREE OH ONE DOLLY. DOLLY
I THAT MEASURE IS OUT WITH
TWENTY. AB TWENTY THREE OH SEVEN
DALI DALI I THAT MEASURE IS OUT
TWENTY. AB TWO EIGHT SIX EIGHT
DOLLY. DOLLY I THAT MEASURE IS
OUT WITH NINETEEN. WHICH FILE
ITEM INTO.
YEAH. THE QUESTION IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THE GAVEL DOWN OKAY
YEAH.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO DOLLY I
TO KNOW THAT MEASURE IS OUT WITH
FOURTEEN.
WE'RE DURING THE MEETING.